-Each year Toastmasters International conducts
the Video Speech Contest designed specifically
for members of undistricted clubs.
Clubs that participate, conduct a speech contest,
and submit a video of their 1st place winner
to be judged by a panel of Toastmasters members.
I am pleased to share with you the 1st place
winner of the 2020-2021 Video Speech Contest.
-Our first speaker for tonight, Roderick Grech,
with his speech, Want It.
Want It, Roderick Grech.
The stage is yours.
Where there is a will, there is a way, but
do you know what it means or how to find the
will that finds you the way?
That's about what-what you can pick up in
the next five minutes.
contest your toastmaster, welcome guests.
Let's sketch a picture; in secondary school
I wasn't exactly your exemplary student.
My sister?
Serial prize winner, year-in, year-out.
I on the other hand was also a prize winner…for
the lowest mark in all the school.
The education system and teaching methods
didn't quite appeal to me, so I refused to
have anything to do with it.
But this was 1985 and the clock had already
started running six months to the old levels
that would determine the rest of my future.
Of course, the writing was on the wall.
I was crashing out of one of the best schools
as a failure.
I had crushed our biggest source of our mother's
pride: a successful son.
In my catalogue of regrets that sticks out
like a sore thumb.
My dad on the other hand sounded cooler about
it.
For one December Sunday morning he walks to
my room, “Son, there's a storm brewing next
week, will you help-come to help me pull the
boat up?”
Were it not the calm before the storm, it's
so easy to have thought it was summer.
That warm December Sunday morning as we stood
in hip-deep water with the sun shining overhead
as what we're seeing proceeded, Dad turns
to me and says, “Son, relax.
Take a deep breath.”
And then he gently pushes my head into the
water.
He keeps my head submerged.
When he senses I'm starting to feel uncomfortable,
he counts five more seconds, then, “What
was it that you wanted most when your face
was in the water?”
“What do you mean, Dad?
Air to breathe!
What do you mean?
Come on.”
“Son, if you want your life to be a success,
want it like the air you wanted to breathe
when your face was in the water.
Want it, that you forget to eat drink and
sleep.
Want it as if it's life-threatening, as if
you'd rather die than live without it.
Want it, because otherwise your life, you
might be wasting your life.”
What on earth would you have felt if you were
instead of me?
My reaction: ‘this moment of insanity, it
will pass.’
That was me.
Ladies and gentlemen, that was my final warning,
and I didn't even see it coming.
Can you see how easy it is to become addicted
to inaction?
That is the result of wishing.
I had many wishes for success, architect,
engineer pilot, but I had shot them all down
one by one.
Not by doing something wrong, but simply by
doing nothing.
Inaction.
Neither creating nor destroying; letting be,
inaction.
That is the result of wishing.
The following month, January 1986, something
bizarre happened.
We were at school during lunch break, and
I saw all my classmates eagerly swarming around
our physics teacher, a short, young, 25-year-old
fresh graduate from University, which was
rather unusual.
As I moved closer, I heard that he was telling
us eager 15-year-old boys how to win a date
with a girl.
What he said stunned me.
Rightly or wrongly, he claimed that the top
criteria a girl uses to decide whether to
accept a date with a boy is his academic results.
No one around me noticed, but if you were
inside of me, you had to have felt a crushing
blow of disappointment.
I had nothing to show in that department.
My desperation became my inspiration.
I asked my sister, my friends for notes, tried
to cram into my head even what I couldn't
understand.
I'll never forget the sight of my mother walking
down to the kitchen at three o'clock in the
morning where I used to study, wondering what's
gotten into me, with my dinner there is still
uneaten, such that I would eat it for breakfast.
Hey, hey, hey, could that be what my dad meant
when he said want it that you forget to eat
drink and sleep?
I understood him then.
Make no mistake, I made it to sixth form by
the skin of my teeth.
But that experience, the stress, the pressure,
it taught me one thing: that you can want
whatever you wish, and it will make a hell
of a difference.
What is it that you might be currently wishing
as we speak?
Perhaps losing weight, a promotion, or earning
the respect of your boss.
How about wanting it like I wanted a date
when I was 15?
Here's how you can do it in three steps: 1,
want it as if your life depends on it.
In my case, winning a date at 15 years of
age meant the world to me.
Want it as if you'd rather die than live without
it, want it like the air you want to breathe
when you're out of breath.
2, become obsessed about it.
You know you want something when you think
about it every minute of every day.
Whilst you’re shaving, doing your makeup,
driving, while you’re stuck in traffic,
waiting for an elevator, waiting for a meeting
to start…instead of you chasing your dream,
your dream chases you.
If wanting something could change a school
failure like me to gra-qualify as a professional,
get an MBA, become a pilot, open my own business,
then what can wanting do to you?
And finally, um, it's okay to have a wish
list, but not a want list.
Want only one thing but want it with all your
heart and all your soul, because when you
find yourself wanting everything, that's a
sure sign that you're dangerously close to
really wanting nothing.
And finally on a light-hearted note, for the
educators who might be listening to this,
if teaching teenage boys how to win a date
with a girl is not on the curriculum, it should
be.
It will get them interested.
Friends, ladies and gentlemen, remember this:
don’t wish it, just want it.
Contest Chair.
[Applause]